how much Jedi mullet is the proper
amount of Jedi mullets I think there's a
fair amount of Jedi mullet this is gonna
be me talking about the final season of
Clone Wars I'm gonna go ahead and give a
spoiler warning I'm erring on the side
of caution on this one I feel like this
is generally speaking spoiler free but
at a point the chronology ends up at a
point where something's gonna happen you
know what's gonna happen so I'm gonna
talk about what I liked about the angle
I saw it from in here so spoiler warning
better too careful they're not careful
enough so Clone Wars season 7 this is
the final season of Star Wars Clone Wars
the show was just kind of cancelled we
were like so did we just go into Revenge
of the Sith so I'm glad they were able
to revisit it from one final season and
before I get into season 7 I'm gonna
give you my backstory on Star Wars Clone
Wars how I saw it versus how I see it I
don't know if I've told the story before
not sure can't remember age am i right
so when Clone Wars first came out I was
really resistant to it I was like I
don't like anything about this Anakin
has an apprentice what he's a master I
always liked that line when I left you I
was but the learner now I am the master
now he is someone's master though they
do not grant him the rank of Master I
don't like that Anakin has an apprentice
no and then people were like know what
actually it's getting good now you
should totally watch it and this this
next parts the most small-minded thing I
was like I don't want to I don't want to
watch anything that might validate or
legitimize the prequels like I say I
already said small-minded [ __ ] that's
that's a child's mindset that's why
would you not watch something that might
be good in fear that it might be good
and even so good it might make something
else feel better growth oh wait age am i
right that's the good thing about age
and so I watched Clone Wars and it was
actually really enjoyable if you want to
catch up on Clone Wars but you're like
oh wow there's a lot of episodes there
are cheat sheets out there that show you
the really important storyline episodes
that you can watch the ones you can skip
versus the ones that you should watch it
to google it you'll find it but it's
compelling stuff you really get the
feeling that Anakin and obi-wan their
war buddies they're actually war buddies
with the clones like Rex becomes a big
player in it which is very important for
what I'm about to talk about in season 7
we're still in the set up of this video
trying to speed through it hold on
mannequins apprentice ahsoka tano I was
like she's actually a cool character I
welcome her you know weirdly the thing I
now run into is the thing I've run into
with Clone Wars thus
for season seven does nothing to make
this feeling subside and that is I just
feel like a soca means more to Anakin
than Padme I'm not talking about
romantic capacity but in terms of family
in terms of closeness I just through
watching Clone Wars and through season
seven I just feel like Anakin's closer
to ahsoka like if the Riddler had ahsoka
and Padme in cylindrical tubes hanging
over pits and he was like you gotta
choose one to live and Anakin couldn't
find his way out of it
he'd be like a Sokolov sorry bad man
right I can't be the only one who feels
that way so now they get to season seven
the first thing I noticed is that in
season seven the animation is just after
than ever I mean the animation always
got better with Clone Wars it's just
kind of how technology and season after
seasons is kind of how it's gonna go but
this season the contrasts the animation
is just top-notch there were some times
I look at that Darth Maul was like you
weirdly look like Rey Park it's okay
we're getting into it in the first four
episodes we're getting reacquainted with
the clones and the Clone Wars and they
got to get echo back from the Borg
collective I was like this is best of
both worlds I've seen this before
don't take it the wrong way Star Wars a
lot of things remind me of Star Trek to
be fair a lot of things also remember
it's okay the first four episodes they
aren't really needed
oh sweet then the next four episodes
started it was like a Sokka where's she
been let's see and wow those four
episodes were boring oh my god laughs
bored as [ __ ] I was like I'm glad I'm
seeing her ahsoka is been a while but
did it have to be some boring smuggler
plot I just I wasn't digging it maybe
it's cuz it reminded me too much as solo
I was okay he got Kessel and you got
Darth Maul dabbling in the criminal
underworld so that starts now I guess
but I had heard this was really good
okay so it's gonna get good and then it
does last four episodes of Clone Wars
holy [ __ ] that was the stouts time hmm I
don't even think he needed the first
eight episodes it could have just been
the last four I mean everything from the
old-school Lucasfilm logo that comes on
it no longer had the intro since the
interest of Clone Wars
they were always cheesy which I enjoyed
them though because if you haven't
noticed I've gotten a lot cheesier on my
channel as times gone on age
right lose insurers they sound like some
old radio broadcast the date is November
at the 22nd in a place called Times
Square Anakin Skywalker and obi-wan
Kenobi return from the frontlines of the
Clone Wars and they stop by Dexter
jettster Donner for a nice cup of
Ovaltine
Ovaltine have Ovaltine force pushed its
way through your bowels today it didn't
have that anymore it's just like
business a silk is confronting darth
maul darth maul starts figuring out
what's going on that's another thing
Clone Wars did it's not just a soap
ghost not just a Clone Wars is not just
Anakin Skywalker and obi-wan friendship
it's also Darth Maul this person was
just kind of like this Unleashed rabid
dog in Phantom Menace he came a
character Clone Wars did that for him so
she's confronting darth maul darth maul
starts seeing what's going on and then
at a point you're like oh we're in
Revenge of the Sith now like the
timelines that they've met and we know
it happens in Revenge of the Sith oh wow
execute order 66 that was the thing I
didn't know it was gonna go there I
didn't know we were gonna see that but
we see it through ahsoka tano --zz
perspective cuz I'll be honest anytime I
can see order 66 from a different
perspective I really enjoy it because
that's that's a pretty monumental thing
that happens it's very important stuff
and the reason I really liked it in
Clone Wars is because you really feel
like it's it's a sokka's friends you
know like obi-wan Kenobi in Revenge of
the Sith
I still got that feeling where he's like
my clones turned on me I need help
okay your clones your troops your people
you might have been friendly with but
you were not friends with I never got
that feeling that he was friends with
them it was just like well that was very
inconvenient I guess I have a lot more
enemies who were once allies but allies
being a very operative word with a souca
you get the feeling it's like these
friends are trying to kill me and I
don't want to kill them because I still
see them as friends there is a scene
though I'm like the term fish in a
barrel comes to mind she should have
been a fish in a barrel I don't know how
she lived through that [ __ ] I like if
Ciotti Mundi got wasted I don't know how
is Sokka lived through it it's just like
a bunch of blasted she's just deflecting
all of it they're getting Clone Wars
like a proper war cartoon more animation
whatever you want to call it everyone
has the aim of Cobra commandos when they
need to not hit something even in this
season I was like can you all focus up
your aim on
on him that would help you out a lot so
it's glad to see that angle of it
there's actually something that is
referenced in rebels that they actually
do show in here it could have just
remained a throwaway line in rebels but
it's actually a story
I appreciated the hell out of that
another thing I liked about this season
of Clone Wars I was kind of worried
because Clone Wars had a lot of grit to
it you know people getting stabbed with
lightsabers impaled killed I always
thought the Clone Wars was darker and
grittier than rebels and I didn't want
them to nerf this season but no people
die they're getting paled they get shot
in the face there's death I like that I
appreciate the fact that there's this
continuity in the violence it's
important stuff and when it ends it ends
there was some speculation I think for a
hot second of whether or not there might
be another season of Clone Wars no I
don't see it unless they go back like
Clone Wars the Wonder here is the
Forgotten times which I don't care to
see it's done now and you really feel
like it's done it it fight it caught up
with Revenge of the Sith and now Clone
Wars can fully be seen and realized for
what it is I mean regardless of my
feelings initially when it came out the
fact remains Clone Wars legitimized the
prequels for a lot of people who didn't
like the prequels like Clone Wars only
served to heighten the experience for
people I still stick to the fact that
movies shouldn't need a TV show to
really flesh it out but that was a
situation we were in
and I really noticed Clone Wars was that
thing when I referencing in videos and
in conversations the fact that Anakin's
turned was very abrupt
because there's no second first
impression that was the first impression
I had with it he was just this guy was
like it was like a punk youth and he had
problems man he's like I'm gonna arrest
you Chancellor you know I will kill
children why not it seems the thing to
do but as I kept referencing it more and
more as time went on and Clone Wars was
out and kept coming out and had more
seasons more and more the conversation
was like no it's not abrupt
it's very fleshed out in Clone Wars
there's a whole generation of kids who
will grow up never knowing the world
without Clone Wars and I've said it
before the prequels have been validated
in the eyes of the fandom and I
genuinely
leave Clone Wars is a big part in making
that a reality
in that it's important for Star Wars as
a whole it can't be overstated
it's like Clone Wars it's the Frog DNA
in Jurassic Park you know like the
prequels where the dinosaur DNA but
there were gaps in the code you didn't
have enough to have a living thing and
then Clone Wars comes along and fills in
the gene sequence gaps and there you go
now you can create a living thing I find
that very fascinating and season seven
of Clone Wars really stuck the landing
and hammering at home first four
episodes or episodic as hell next four
episodes are boring as hell but the last
four episodes if you look at them half
an hour each four episodes comes out to
about two hours which means the last
four episodes which definitely do feel
detached from the previous eight
episodes I feel like their own thing
these last four episodes of Clone Wars
is the best Star Wars movie I've seen in
a while and who knows maybe some years
from now they'll come out with some
animated series that'll completely flush
out the sequel movies maybe and then
we'll realize that time is but a loop a
loose stitch in the universal cloth a
streamer might seize upon a chance a
fatal slip and plunge the fate of
planets into chaos or so Star Wars Clone
Wars the series the final season the
last four episodes have you seen them
what do you think about them whatever
you thought comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]